what is the relationship between our
diet and spirituality oh there's every
connection between diet and spirituality
the first atom fell on the question of diet
the second adam conquered on the question of diet
diet and spirituality are cannot be separated
many of us we struggle with things
that are the result of the way we eat
i'll never forget um someone wrote me
and said i have strong sexual addictions
well i am no sexual addiction counselor
but my first recommendation was
give up meat and the person did that for about six
weeks and wrote back and said to me i am amazed
at how this fiery passion has subsided
since i gave up me in the united states
the most the number one preventable cause of
death today is lifestyle it used to be smoking
now it is lifestyle god arranged for people to
eat before sin in the new world we will also
eat eating and spirituality cannot be separated
the sixth commandment says thou shalt not kill
many people kill themselves with their mouths are
you following me we eat ourselves to death by the
things we eat and how much we eat so the sixth
commandment which is the source of the health
laws because when the bible says thou shalt
not kill it means as well don't kill yourself
and we kill ourselves by the way we eat that's
why in leviticus 11 we have instructions regarding
what to eat and to show you how important eating
is in leviticus from chapter about 11 to about 15
there are varying kinds of uncleanness if you had
leprosy that was the worst kind of uncleanness
if there was mold on your dress that was unclean
if there was mold in your house that was unclean
dandruff was considered unclean
if a man had a nocturnal emission
that was unclean and of course animals were
unclean now listen to this of all the forms
of uncleanness all of them could be treated
except unclean animals there was nothing that
could be done to make an unclean animal clean
so when god said don't eat unclean foods it's
not just for the jews or just for their era is for
all generations for all nations let me say again
all forms of uncleanness could be reversed by
certain rituals except the uncleanness of animals
and this goes all the way back before the flood
in genesis 7 verse 1 the bible says and the lord
said unto noah come thou and all thy house into
the ark for thee have i seen righteous before me
in this generation of every clean beast thou shalt
take today by seven the male and the female and of
every beast every that's not clean by two the
male and the female so we had unclean and clean
even before the flood came in in 3rd john verse
2 beloved i wish above all things that i must
prosper and be in health if you read isaiah
58 which talks about the mission of the church
when we do what's right the bible says
then shall thy health spring forth like
the morning so health is associated with
spirituality you cannot separate the two
you